today we're talking about cloud summit
series data analytics skills and iam for
cloud sql i'm ryan and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
register for our 2022 google cloud
summit series and be among the first to
learn about new solutions across data
machine learning collaboration security
sustainability and more
you'll hear from experts explore
customer perspectives engage with
interactive demos and gain valuable
insights to help you accelerate your
business transformation
our first event is coming up in april
and you'll want to bookmark the google
cloud summit series website for all the
updates
these days companies must deliver simple
experiences to be successful
for many cloud providers this means
enabling tightly integrated data
offerings that simplify the data
delivery process without losing sight of
the sophisticated needs of the modern
data consumer
it begs the question to stay ahead of
data cloud market trends in 2022 should
data practitioners invest their time in
specializing their data cloud skill sets
or instead invest their time
generalizing their data cloud skill sets
check out the article to learn more
if you're responsible for administering
cloud sql instances securing your
databases is one of your top priorities
however as your number of users on your
sql instances grows you may find
yourself challenged to keep access
locked down we're happy to announce that
cloud sql support for iem conditions is
now generally available
iam conditions are part of cloud
identity and access management or iam
the service that cloud sql and other
google cloud services rely on for
determining access to cloud resources
check out the blog for the full post
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud